TONIGHT.
JEB ZUCKER, I HOPE YOU ARE
WATCHING TONIGHT'S BREAKING
NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
RADICAL LEFT WING CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR JERRY MOON BEAM
BROWN SIGNED A LAW MAKING
CALIFORNIA A SANCTUARY
STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S LAWLESS
LAWMAKERS ARE NOW LITERALLY
BARRING POLICE FROM
DETERMINING THE CITIZENSHIP
STATUS OF ANYONE CHARGED
WITH A CRIME THEREBY
PREVENTING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM EFFECTIVELY
DEPORTING CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND ENFORCING
FEDERAL LAW.
BUT NOW SOME LOCALITIES ARE
STARTING TO FIGHT BACK.
NOW THE CITY OF LAMB TOAST LOS A
NOW THE CITY OF LAMB TOAST LOS I
NOW THE CITY OF LAMB TOAST LOS O
NOW THE CITY OF LAMB TOAST LOS .
THEY HAVE VOTED TO JOIN
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LAWSUIT
AGAINST CALIFORNIA.
IN THE MEANTIME.
THE COUNTY'S SHERIFF'S
OFFICE IMPLEMENTED NEW PLAN
TO SKIRT CALIFORNIA'S INSANE
SANCTUARY LAWS.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
ASSIST THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN DEPORTING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS CONVICTED
OF SERIOUS CRIMES AND, OF
COURSE, THOSE STANDING IN
THE WAY OF THE RULE OF LAW.
NOW, THE PLAN IS REALLY
SIMPLE.
THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE WILL NOW MAKE THE
NAMES AND RELEASE DATES FOR
EVERY PRISONER PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE IN AN ONLINE
DATABASE CALLED WHOSE IN
JAIL?
THIS WILL ALLOW ICE TO
CROSS-REFERENCE IDENTITIES
AND DEPORT THOSE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE
CONVICTED OF CRIMES AND, OF
COURSE, A THREAT TO SOCIETY.
AND IN RESPONSE, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA, WELL HE IS NOW
ISSUING A VEILED THREAT TO
THOSE THAT CHALLENGE
CALIFORNIA'S SANCTUARY
STATUS WHICH, OF COURSE,
DEFIES FEDERAL LAW.
WATCH THIS.
>> I HAVE TO TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT WHAT ORANGE COUNTY
IS SAYING AND POSSIBLY
DOING.
STATE LAW IS STATE LAW.
AND IT'S MY JOB TO ENFORCE
STATE LAW.
I WILL DO SO.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY JURISDICTION,
INCLUDING ORANGE COUNTY
UNDERSTAND WHAT STATE LAW
REQUIRES OF THE PEOPLE AND
THE SUBDIVISIONS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
>> Sean: I ACTUALLY DARE THE
STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA TO DO.
THIS IF HE DOES, THAT MEANS
THE OAKLAND MAYOR CAN BE
ARRESTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR AIDING AND
ABETTING FEDERAL CRIMINAL
ALIENS BY TIPPING THEM OFF
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
NOW, WE'LL HAVE A LOT MORE
ON THIS LATER IN THE SHOW
WHEN THE ORANGE COUNTY UNDER
SHERIFF WILL JOIN US.
ALSO TONIGHT CALIFORNIA
LUNANCY CONTINUES.
THAT STATE SET TO SUE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AGAIN
THIS TIME ON THE UPCOMING
2020 U.S. CENSUS.
THE CENSUS WILL ASK
NONRESPOND DENTS OR THOSE
THAT WANT TO RESPOND ARE YOU
A U.S. CITIZEN?
THAT'S IT CAREFUL ATTORNEY
GENERAL SAID THE QUESTION IS
NOT JUST A BAD IDEA ALSO
ILLEGAL.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL I BEG
TO DIFFER.
THERE WAS EVEN MORE HYSTERIA
OF COURSE IN THE LEFT WING,
ABUSIVELY BIASED SO-CALLED
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT DO WE WANT FROM THE
CENSUS?
WE WANT AN ACCURATE COUNT.
LET'S DEFER TO THE EXPERTS.
WILL THIS HELP WITH
ACCURACY?
IT WILL NOT.
PEOPLE WILL NOT ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
>> LET'S BE REALISTIC ABOUT
THIS?
DO WE THINK THIS IS ABOUT
GETTING AN ACCURATE VIEW OF
THE CENSUS AND PROTECTING
VOTING RIGHTS OR IS IT TO
AND IN FACT SUPPRESS
MINORITY VOTING.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
MOTIVATION HERE SEEMS TO BE
QUITE SO ARUSE FOR ADDING A
QUESTION THAT COULD VERY
SERIOUSLY DEPRESS
PARTICIPATION AND RESULT IN
A FAILED CENSUS ALL
TOGETHER.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
CRITICS ARGUE ULTIMATELY
TARGET IMMIGRANTS.
FEWER RESOURCES FOR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES?
>> Sean: THE MAIN GOAL OF
THE CENSUS HAS BEEN TO
DETERMINE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
POPULATION THAT LIVES INSIDE
THE UNITED STATES.
BUT, THE LEFT, MEMBERS OF
THE BIASED PRESS, THEY WANT
YOU TO BELIEVE THAT WE
AREN'T ALLOWED TO DETERMINE
HOW MANY CITIZENS VERSUS
NONCITIZENS ARE ACTUALLY
LIVING HERE.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE
CONSIDERING CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICTS ARE LITERALLY MADE
UP OF WHAT THE POPULATION
IS.
NOTHING SAYS THAT
RESPONSIBLE IMMIGRATION
POLICY, YOU KNOW, LIKE WELL
WHO IS LIVING IN YOUR
COUNTRY REALLY HARD
QUESTION.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THAT IN A
SECOND.
WHEN IT DOES COME TO THE
WALL ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
THERE IS BIG NEWS OUT OF
WASHINGTON.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS.
THE PRESIDENT WILL USE
MILITARY AND NATIONAL
DEFENSE FUNDING TO COVER
INITIAL CONSTRUCTION COST OF
THE LAW CITING NEAR NEWSCAST
RISKS BY UNPROTECTED
BORDERS.
THIS IS A HUGE STEP FORWARD
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION AND
IT WOULD BE A POLITICAL
VICTORY AND SERIOUS PROGRESS
REPORTS TO BATTLE AND SECURE
OUR BORDERS.
NOW, HERE'S WHAT THE DEPUTY
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
HOGAN GIDLEY HAD TO SAY
ABOUT THIS ON "FOX &
FRIENDS" EARLIER TODAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS NOW
SAYING KIND OF HINTED AROUND
AT LEAST ON TWITTER OVER THE
WEEKEND THAT HE COULD USE
ALL OF THAT MILITARY
FUNDING, THERE WAS A LOT OF
MILITARY FUNDING GOING INTO
THE POCKETBOOKS OF THOSE MEN
AND WOMEN FIGHTING FOR OUR
COUNTRY BUT THERE IS A LOFT
EXTRA MONEY TO BE USED, MORE
THAN WHAT THEY ASKED FOR.
MORE THAN WHAT THE WHITE
HOUSE ASKED FOR, SO THERE IS
TALK THAT HE MIGHT USE THAT
EXTRA MONEY TO BUILD THE
WALL SINCE HE DIDN'T GET THE
FUNDING, HE ONLY GOT 1.6.
STEVE: THAT WAS HIS TWITTER.
>> HIS TWITTER SAYING MIGHT
USE THIS FUNDING TO BUILD
THE WALL.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GET AHEAD
OF HIS ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> WHAT ANNOUNCEMENT?
>> IF IS HE GOING TO MAKE
THAT NOW.
HOW HE SPENDS THE MONEY TO
BUILD WALL.
ONE OF THE VICTORIES IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHICH WAS
ACTUALLY BUILDING A WALL.
>> Sean: WHEN THE FUNDING
BECOMES REALITY, PRESIDENT
TRUMP WILL BE FULL FILING A
MAJOR CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY
STARTED TO LOOK FOR
PROTOTYPES FOR THIS WALL.
ALL RIGHT, ANOTHER TOP STORY
TONIGHT THE
TONIGHT PHE
TONIGHT PRESS SPENT A YEAR
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THE NARRATIVE IS CRUMBLING
RIGHT BEFORE THEIR EYES.
THE LEFT SAID PRESIDENT
TRUMP WOULD NEVER EVER BE
TOUGH ON RUSSIA.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THE DAILY
HYSTERIA, TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK HE IS AFRAID OF
THE PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA.
>> WHY?
>> I THINK ONE CAN SPECULATE
AS TO WHY THAT THE RUSSIANS
MAY HAVE SOMETHING ON HIM
PERSONALLY.
THAT THEY COULD ALWAYS ROLL
OUT AND MAKE HIS LIFE MORE
DIFFICULT.
>> IT'S SO CLEAR AT THIS
POINT THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND HIS ASSOCIATES, SOMEBODY
HAS SOMETHING ON DONALD
TRUMP.
>> THAT MAY BE SOMETHING
THAT TURNS THE KEY IN THE
RUSSIA PROBE IS FIGURING OUT
WHY THIS PRESIDENT IS SO
DEFERENTIAL TO PUTIN AND TO
RUSSIA AND IF THERE IS SOME
SORT OF KOMPROMAT THAT THEY
HAVE ON HIM.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS AFRAID, A
POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT
THERE AT SEA FOR HIM.
WE WILL CALL IT HURRICANE
VLADIMIR.
THE WHOLE RUSSIA THING.
>> THEY MAKE THESE DECISIONS
TIME AND TIME AGAIN IN A WAY
THAT MAKES IT APPEAR THAT
THEY ARE HOSTAGES.
THAT HE IS VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
HOSTAGE.
>> Sean: THAT WAS JUST LAST
WEEK.
THEY HAVE SOMETHING ON
TRUMP.
HE CAN'T ACT AGAINST PUTIN.
YESTERDAY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THEY
ANNOUNCED TOUGH NEW ACTIONS
AGAINST VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
HIS REGIME IN RESPONSE TO
THE POISONING OF A FORMER
SPY AND HIS DAUGHTER IN
GREAT BRITAIN.
OH, THE TRUMP POLICY
INCLUDES THE EXPULSION OF 60
RUSSIAN DIPLOMATS, THE
CLOSURE OF RUSSIA'S
CONSULATE IN SEATTLE.
PRETTY TOUGH.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THIS IS A VERY AGGRESSIVE
MOVE AGAINST PUTIN'S REGIME.
IT SENDS A POWERFUL MESSAGE
THAT THE UNITED STATES AND
OUR ALLIES ARE NOT GOING TO
BOW DOWN TO MOSCOW.
I GUESS THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ON TRUMP.
EVEN FORMER CIA DIRECTOR
TURNED CNN SHILL MICHAEL
HAYDEN IS HE PRAISING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WOW, HELL HAS FROZEN OVER.
>> FELT FAMILIAR.
FELT A BIT LIKE OLD TIMES.
LOOK AT WHAT JUST HAPPENED.
WE ARE TOUGH ON RUSSIA.
CONCERT WITH ALLIES
GLOBALLY.
TOOK A LEADERSHIP ROLE.
VERY UNTRUMPIAN.
I'M VERY HAPPY TO SEE IT.
>> Sean: GLAD WE CAN MAKE
YOU HAPPY.
GENERAL HAYDEN IS RIGHT.
SOME IN THE MEDIA ARE STILL
DOING WHATEVER THEY CAN TO
DISCREDIT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
LATEST MOVE.
BY THE WAY, OBAMA NEVER DID
ANYTHING THIS TOUGH.
HE WAS TELLING THE DMITRY
MEDVEDEV TELL VLADIMIR I
WILL HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY
AFTER THE ELECTION.
>> ALMOST LIKE THE OLD DAYS
WHERE THE UNITED STATES AND
ALLIES SOMETHING OF A
POSITION.
NOT SO GOOD PART OF THIS,
JOE, FOREIGN POLICY ON AUTO
PILOT.
WE STILL COULD HAVE DONE A
LOT MORE.
IF WE REALLY WANT TO HURT
THE RUSSIANS AND PUTIN
SPECIFICALLY YOU GO AFTER
THE BANKS HERE, WHERE THERE
IS STILL A LOT OF RUSSIAN
MONEY BEING HOUSED.
>> I THINK WHAT'S HAPPENED
IS THE ALLIES HAVE KIND OF
SHAMED THE PRESIDENT INTO
THIS ACTION TODAY.
WE WOULD BE STANDING ALONE
OBVIOUSLY IF WE DIDN'T DO
SOMETHING IT ALLOWS THE
PRESIDENT COVER.
HE CAN SAY LOOK, I'M TOUGH
ON RUSSIA.
WHAT PUTIN IS LAUGHING AT
TRUMP TONIGHT BECAUSE HE
KNOWS HE HAS LICENSE TO DO
WHATEVER HE WANTS.
>> DID THE ADMINISTRATION
SEND A STRONG ENOUGH SIGNAL?
>> NOT YET.
IF YOU WANT TO SEND A STRONG
SIGNAL, I THINK AT SOME
POINT HAVE YOU GOT TO LOOK
AT SOME MONEY SANCTIONS.
YOU HAVE GOT TO GET AT PUTIN
AND THE INDIVIDUALS AROUND
HIM.
>> Sean: YOU MEAN LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP PURSUING
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE?
THAT THE HEART OF THE
RUSSIAN ECONOMY?
GUESS WHAT?
THAT WILL HURT VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND ANY ECONOMIC
CHANCES THAT HE HAS.
I TOLD YOU JOURNALISM IS
DEAD AND BURIED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
NOT SURPRISING TO HEAR THE
MEDIA BENDING OVER BACKWARDS
TO BASH PRESIDENT TRUMP EVEN
WHEN HE DOES SOMETHING TOUGH
AND STRONG AND GOOD.
YOU WILL NOT HEAR THIS FROM
THE SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS
OVER AT THESE OTHER NETWORKS
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THIS IS THE LATEST TOUGH
ACTION FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE THEY
WON'T TELL YOU BUT EARLIER
IN MARCH THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED CRITICAL NEW
ECONOMIC SANCTIONS AGAINST
RUSSIA IN RESPONSE TO
ELECTION MEDDLING IN
FEBRUARY AROUND 300 KREMLIN
LINKED RUSSIAN MERCENARIES
WERE KILLED OR WOUNDED BY
THE U.S. MILITARY.
THAT FOLLOWING RUSSIA'S
AGGRESSIVE ACTIONS NEAR A
BASE IN SYRIA WHERE
AMERICANS WERE STATIONED.
AND, OF COURSE, THIS ALL
COMES AFTER PRESIDENT OBAMA
ESSENTIALLY DID NOTHING BUT
APPEASE AND IGNORE AND SUCK
UP TO VLADIMIR PUTIN YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
NOW, TONIGHT RUSSIA IS
VOWING TO RETALIATE AGAINST
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
TOUGH ACTIONS OH, MAYBE THEY
WILL RELEASE THE INFORMATION
THEY HAVE ON TRUMP BUT
UNLIKE THE OBAMA